Hello Internet!
You know I love me some voting videos.
These, however, are mostly about how
organizations can improve their elections.
But normal people need better voting too.
Say a group of you are trying to decide
what to have for dinner.
There are three options:
Steak Shack - All meat all the time
Veggie Villa - Hope you like lettuce
and Burger Barn - Every burger ever.
(Including the ones made from not-meat?)
Just asking people to pick their favorites
as normal results in three starved carnivores.
Now you could use one of these
better methods I've talked about before.
But seriously, who wants to break out
the pens and paper and nerd
to crank the algorithm for a question
that should be answered in under 30 seconds?
No one. So here the fastest way to vote
in a group with none of that stuff required.
Don't blink or you'll miss it.
Hands up if you're good with Steak Shack,
Hands up if you're good with Burger Barn,
Hands up if you're good with Veggie Villa.
Boom
Election over.
Burger Barn domination.
This time, everybody gets to live.
The difference? Letting people vote
more than once.
If you're in a group and picking
from several options quickly,
then this is the way to go.
It's world-changingly great at stopping
arguments like, for example,
in a classroom.
Hey kids! We're gonna watch a movie today!
Because, I just can't, anymore...
So let's go:
Hands up for Terminator 2
Hands up for Spirited Away.
Hands up for WALL-E.
Done. WALL-E it is.
Lazy Bonus! If you're in charge of the vote,
no need to keep an eye out
for those aspiring dictators who
subvert democracy by voting more than once.
Voting more than once
is the whole point.
So, next time you're in a group
trying to decide,
don't just ask for the favorite,
ask for all the OKs.
Best way to decide quickly,
no pen or paper or nerd required.